someone that feels entitled to making
decisions for you show me that you want
me Chase the whole controlling thing
shows you that he cares as well but
that's important in any relationship did
you like a man that has a little bit of
dominance I think controlling and like
constantly checking where you are I feel
like it's a bit too much okay what's the
difference between controlling and
dominance I think a dominant man is
someone that can like make decisions so
you want them to be able to make the
decisions but not the decision of what
to wear about toxic access now whoa this
is a young panel so I'm I'm hoping this
topic still works
no question what what is your definition
of a toxic X
someone that feels entitled to making
decisions for you
I feel like yeah yeah that's a toxic ex
someone that feels entitled to to your
life to your lifestyle but that also
determines on whether you give them that
intact whether you give them that but do
you not like it when a guy has a bit of
like control that with me even though I
have a lot of control in my career and
in my life but I like to feel you know
petite and cute so I like when a man is
like give it to me I'd like to have like
a bit of um controlling that oh where
are you yeah I'm gonna say I want to
know what you care about me because
you'll say like the whole controlling
thing shows you that he cares as well I
think that's important in any
relationship yeah and this is confusing
you're nodding and she says this you
agree because but she's saying the
opposite of what you said
yeah in a controlling way as in
I would want you to show me that you
care I get that I like that I think she
means I can't lie I can't lie to show me
show me that you want me chase me okay
okay so show me that you want me you
don't want them to feel entitled to
making decisions yes but you want him to
chase you okay you I'm just running the
stuff yes
there's a huge difference between
controlling and a bit of dominance and I
think that as a woman I think in a
relationship like a man that has a
little bit of dominance I think
controlling and like constantly checking
where you are I feel like it's a bit too
much in my opinion anyway I feel like
there should be a level of trust in a
relationship
no when I said when I said where like
where are you it's more of like oh are
you safe are you at home yet okay yeah
so that's different yeah okay what's the
difference between controlling and
dominance I think a dominant man is
someone that can like make decisions
like say for example like we're going on
a date okay I'm picking up at eight I'm
taking you somewhere like that's kind of
like dominance or like did you get home
safe or you know checking up on you
making sure you're good but like instead
of being like where are you what are you
doing who are you with show me who
you're with okay you can't wear that
outfit like that is very tough so so you
want them to be able to make the
decisions but not the decision of what
to wear
[Laughter]
today when a man goes when a man goes oh
babe I want you to put that sexy outfit
you look good in that okay that's cute
that means he trusts you though don't
you think there's a level of trust
is manipulation not I don't think you
guys are really aren't answering the
question by what she said what is a
toxic yeah
[Music]
is when two people are going at each
other but in a way where you know that
what one person's saying is not good and
what another person saying not good but
it's like
in your head it's it's good to them but
in the end it's not good so it's like
you guys are fighting and batting like
okay what's like what's this it's like
do you guys yeah you're clashing with
each other yeah you might love each
other to Pieces but if it doesn't work
and you have that Clash all the time
yeah then it's gonna be cool that's what
makes it toxic so extremely exciting
yeah okay knowing that it's not good but
you're still doing and you're still
together
yeah so knowing it's not good but
staying together yeah yeah what about
what about rough patches and marriages
um I think rough patches and marriages I
mean because don't you argue all the
time during a rough patch in a marriage
you wouldn't think I agree but I feel
like if you're married to someone it's a
lifelong commitment and I think those
are things that you should be able to
work through by communication like
there's even like yeah it's couples
therapy even like if you need to do it
if you're willing to like work through
that then you can get through it but
yeah everyone argues yeah see it's just
it's very broad everything you guys are
saying I'm just trying to lock you down
under one thing uh go ahead I feel like
it depends on what the topic of
conversation is and what you guys are
arguing about that then depends if it's
toxic or think where I'm correcting you
and what you're doing is wrong yeah wait
say that again sorry that all depends on
what you guys are arguing about for you
for YouTube for you to know whether it
is toxic or thing where you're just
correcting a person because
pictures on Instagram following bad
girls that is toxic in itself I'm sorry
I think it's don't you think it's toxic
to be constantly looking who he's
following and
sometimes it takes two to tango yeah but
at the end of the day yeah if you really
like one that person and you like the
person you're with like why do you need
to seek elsewhere why do you need to
have Temptation yeah but why are you
gonna get upset over an Instagram like
true because there's no actual double
tap in it because you clearly like what
you're saying if you like what you're
seeing no it's gone you don't think
you're looking for drama in a way yeah
I'm trying to see if I can trust him
you're doing it for trust me
shouldn't you go into relationships in
good faith no no no she's not everything
she said is by the reason why I'm saying
yes as you know we are gen Z the way
things were back then it's totally
different you guys didn't have social
media you guys didn't have phones but I
mean thank you guys I mean you've never
had before I had a phone
exactly like you'll go to them you you
traps them right but now trapsing is
double tapping because it says a lot
about a man sexually discipline as well
that's really cool what about what about
when girls post selfies while in a
relationship
is double tapping and liking a girl's
picture that's showing that yes you're
you're attracted to them and when they
say would you say a toxic girl post
selfies and and while she's in a
relationship if her intention sorry if
her intention is to get a reaction out
of that from a certain audience then yes
but what if his intention was just to
like the picture why would you just like
a and if anything let's have an open
conversation yeah you know what that's
yeah because I don't like a single guys
picture or you know what I mean because
I would why would I give them the
satisfaction of seeing Mia me in their
notifications I mean to be honest I
don't really think that liking a girl's
Instagram picture is that deep I think
obviously if they go ahead and DM them
and message them yeah but you can
appreciate someone you're praying you're
putting the goal but you can just go
through
couldn't you say the same thing about
women that post suggestive Instagram
pictures while in a relationship that
they're they're looking for attention
even if it's just a selfie you know that
men are not you know how men are you
know what if they're in an open
relationships
complete different topics yeah
it really it really it's about body and
female empowerment of the day so we've
got all things
it really just it really just sounds
like you want you want to do whatever
you want but he can't do whatever he
wants yeah
[Laughter]
with a man there should be a level of
trust there so you just you know that
already if he's like another Instagram
post it's never that deep because
of this because the trust isn't but you
shouldn't be in a relationship with
someone you don't trust the trust should
be there before you get into something
about that happening during a dating
like when you're dating like the dating
base so you don't have to allowed it I
mean should it shouldn't you go into a
relationship in good faith like assuming
them but let's say you're just dating
you're not in a relationship but you're
about to get into the relationship but
then you you know what I mean it's I
kind of think you're overthinking okay
too much yeah I mean if you guys are
together and it's something serious and
then he starts to go and follow loads
that's different that's a bit different
I'm talking in the dating phase where
you're getting to know each other and
he's still lacking other girls people
you're both single so you have the
rights to do whatever you want I think
unless it becomes something serious if
you're single you're going to chat to
whoever and they're going to chat to
whoever and then if you decide that it's
something that is worth trying for then
you guys cut off your links or you do
whatever
because relationship with more based of
trust right yeah and then dating is more
for
I don't even know man
I honest
guys finish men or what a man I just
said you some of you just need a pattern
up some yeah a lot of people you just
don't who do you think is more
promiscuous men or women hmm
another question for me I feel like
they're both promiscuous in different
ways I feel like females I feel like you
know what these days some of these some
of these females are using Instagram
like a dating app I don't know what is
going on they're posting that all these
random pictures that bro you don't have
to do all of that focus on yourself in
your career that are you trying to get
attention from I think a lot of God
there's attention seeking girls on
Instagram when it comes to pick one take
one who's who's more promiscuous
promiscuous yeah if we're talking about
like visually
you know I'm talking about who's who
sleeps around more oh oh who sees okay
I'll miss my question you say man yeah I
say men men again yeah I'm gonna give
you guys a stat did you know one in
three men under 30 are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year do you
think one in three women under 30 are
either virgins or haven't had sex in the
past year
no
I was gonna say I'm sorry is that true
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's crazy
though do you guys do you guys um do you
guys like tall guys are you tall guys
you like short Kings I mean as long as
that's older than me I'm sure as it is
have you heard have you heard girls say
that they need a guy over six foot yes
all the time
yes
as long as you're taller than me do you
have an X over six foot
yeah yeah
it's okay it's okay so what what percent
of guys do you think are over six foot
one percent
lucky guess 56 56 I'm gonna say 35 35 42
42. huh
um Harmony
I'm not drunk guys
um I would say 30 30 so it's only 15 of
guys wow and now think about it think
about it if uh how many people said they
have an ax over six foot you did you did
you did all sleeping with the same guys
personally but women in general are
sleeping with the same guys because 80
of women want 20 of men
no that is Matt so so the reason like
women think men are trash and they think
they're sleeping around all the time is
because we go for such a small
percentage of of men and they are
sleeping around all the time the
majority of men if you go to Tesco you
think they're getting a new play
so you'll see it and you're saying it
comes to our choice in men what that
makes us think the rest of the same I
think that's the first statement
actually yeah I agree with that
yes that's a very interesting thing
because I feel like a lot of the time
like women when they're younger yeah
they go for like the bad boy or like
something and as you get older you kind
of realize that like certain traits that
you would like find attractive like
someone who's emotionally unavailable
they become unattractive as you get
older you're only 22 right I know what
have you been in a relationship but you
know I've seen so many like people get
into relationships and it's just and it
all flops something and it's like yeah
I'm scared
I'm actually terrified so um have you
guys had a toxic ax yep yes
um it wasn't an X but I guess yeah sort
of toxic yeah okay nope I've had people
who felt like they're obliged
by having a say in my life because they
like me
yes or no I need a yes
no me I would say yeah yeah okay um how
long were you involved with your toxic
ex a year and a half yeah did you love
him yes yes five years five years oh my
oh my goodness that is mad five years
yeah that is crazy did you love him last
time you know it's toxic five years you
didn't love him I don't know it was I
wasn't like in a relationship with him
but it was just a very toxic situation
so
okay so no you didn't love him yes or no
um I don't know maybe it was love to me
at the time at the time I don't think
his love like now when I look back on it
okay wow five years okay so I actually
have not been in a relationship like
properly where I can say oh you know
with boyfriend and girlfriend yeah but
I've been in a lot of situations where
I'm thinking again and I would say yeah
I must go and it's been quite toxic so
yeah you would yes yes and how long were
you with him
oh
um I was with him for about
must be not five months not long five
months yeah I'm a busy woman I haven't
really got time did you did you love him
no no
okay so question question based on this
panel two out of four of you said you
loved your toxic acts and you were with
him for over a year would you say by
that statement young women love toxic
men
yes yes do you know what it is I think
when you're young you don't really know
your boundaries properly yet and a lot
of people put up with stuff that they
wouldn't usually put up with like I
always say now like men only treat you
bad if you let them if you let them yeah
if you let them treat you man and you
don't if you don't respect your
boundaries then they're gonna walk all
over you and I think that's just bad
guys though I think that's just bad guys
like I think there's something about
young women like picking the Bad Boys
[Music]
they're gonna walk all over you if you
treat them well that's just yeah no 100
I'm the youngest in here and I will tell
you yeah it's because it's exciting it's
like almost like an adrenaline
bounce off each other I knew it when she
was talking about the following I was
like she likes to draw yeah literally
but I also feel like yeah it's not sorry
I also feel like it depends on your
circumstances as the young girl because
I with me I depended on my ex for living
for food for everything so I felt like I
was chained to him like I was his had no
one else you know so it was like
circumstances made me and be in that
situation so what about that situation
was toxic uh well he was basically like
cheating around flirting with other
girls at work
um I didn't know obviously because I was
just like at home I didn't have a job I
was just like living off him you know
but I feel like he he
um had that power over me because I
allowed him to obviously so yeah so she
was it more than cheating or was he a
good boyfriend outside it was more than
cheating I was involved in certain
things as well so I felt like if he did
if he could do I could do it to you okay
so you were cheating you were both
cheating on each other then couldn't you
just done a standstill and then got
along
um no because I mean
we did have conversations about it we we
were very open with each other but then
obviously the cheating was lies he
because he kept it from me so did you
keep your cheating from him no I told
him I told him you don't know you don't
want to know who I cheated on him with
but um
is he famous no he's not no no no okay
do I know no you don't oh
okay I cheated on him with his sister
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm a changed person I am a changed
person I'm a change
why why is sister I'm just gonna sit my
drink me and his sister were really good
friends I mean clearly
what no no worries
friends and obviously one day she said
she wanted to come over and I said cool
he was at work we got drunk and she
started like pouncing on me
okay I'm not even trying to like I'm so
serious like she and I was like no like
this isn't right and she's like no and
then Boop it happened and I was like
[__] and then you told him yeah I told
him how did he react he almost killed me
was she younger how old was she she was
younger yeah but we had a conversation
about it and
I can't be out with ethnicity anyway
um it's it's almost like common from
where he's from
wearing that
South Africa and stuff wow guys
no but um it's not common but it was
like a thing within his
[Laughter]
because I'm regardless of whether I did
something wrong or not regardless of
whether I hurt someone's feeling or not
I am an honest person and I feel like
that's very very important if you're if
you're talking to someone if you're in a
relationships with someone if you're
just with people anyway you know so I I
just I clarified that with him he got
upset he came back and he was like thank
you for being honest with me you know so
it was like yeah but he was toxic for
cheating on you and not telling you yes
I had to find out would you would you
rather have him told you yes do you
think men lie to women they care about
or that they or they tell the truth to
women they lie to women they care about
and they feel like maybe like certain
characteristics that they have for
example
um some because some women are really
Stern like if you cheat on me that's it
and because they care so much they don't
want to lose you so that thought of
having to lose you would now be in be in
their head obviously and yeah they
wouldn't they wouldn't tell you so
outside of the cheating anything else
toxic or just that
um
yeah we smoked a lot of stuff
okay so I guess that's drugs
I guess that was toxic here okay
um all right what about you
um
what was the question
um what was toxic about you said you had
a toxic situation chip yeah what was
toxic about it um it was very
emotionally abusive so like even I see
myself as a strong person but there's
only so many times you can like get
knocked down and I dealt with it and I
feel like I didn't respect my own
boundaries which led to me being in that
situation
um yeah it was just very unhealthy what
is emotional abuse
um I think to constantly knock someone's
confidence down make them feel bad about
themselves
like what specifically
um
I don't know like it could really be
anything like you know just I'm asking
like to you like what did he say like
what how was he emotionally abusive oh
he just like just used to knock me down
like I used to be a bit slow because I
had a history of like doing like party
drugs okay I feel like it actually
affected my like mental development a
bit like I had a stutter for a long time
like I was a bit slow and it was one of
my biggest insecurities and I used to
get digged out a lot for that like oh
you're so slow you're stupid you know
this and that's what he would say to you
yeah and also
um I lost a lot of weight because of
stress and I was very insecure in my
skin like you're so skinny like lost so
much weight and it just makes you feel
like a bit rubbish about myself
um and what did what did you say to him
back like did you push back or what yeah
I would push back I would tell him like
don't talk to me like that or I don't
like that I'm running because he did
used to like threaten me and stuff but
he used to threaten you yeah he was he
wasn't like threatened threatened to do
like what kill you or no like just to
like you know bring his fists up to me
and stuff I knew he would never do
anything but like yeah it was just not a
nice situation I would always Stand My
Ground about that but I would continue
to put up with it for so long so that's
why
like I was disrespected for so long but
yeah literally after I got out of it I
put on weight like I was I got a glow
like life was good oh we love our happy
ending yeah
um what about no you you said yes
Maybe
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
I relate to her as well because you know
what it is now I'm hearing both the
stories maybe I haven't actually been a
little toxic um relationship we say or
toxic X but everyone has their own
meaning of toxic at the end of the day
obviously I'm sure there is like a
meaning by book but everyone has their
like imagine yeah yeah
yeah you know what I'm trying to say but
yeah basically I think with me obviously
um it wasn't for that long I think I
think was toxic is like he was saying he
wanted to see me but didn't see me and
this was like that for about eight
months so he would say he'd want to see
you and then he wouldn't see you
can you make plans of you and lets you
down and it's like
me you cannot take advantage of me I'll
be like leave then stop leaving me on he
said I'm not leaving you on have you
ever um promised to go on a date and not
get what not went have you been worn off
a guy yeah are you guys all toxic yeah
yeah
yeah but women aren't demonized for it
and that are we call it entertainment
[Laughter]
you can say like a rotation
entertainment hahaha but when a guy says
that he's toxic yeah that's absolutely
because he says the exact same thing
that women can be just as bad as men
though some women are actually demons
like yeah evil pure evil yeah tell me
who are you thinking of what story
no I've just like seen how like some
women treat men and like you know
um some women can be very narcissistic I
think
social media especially has like become
a breeding ground for narcissism in a
lot of people but I do also think the
times thrown around very Loosely and a
lot of people accuse of being a
narcissist when they're actually not
never what girl you said you could think
of a narcissistic girls or a story give
us a team yeah yeah
[Music]
um I mean I could use like my I don't
know I don't know any narcissistic women
stories oh you've heard stories I've
Heard lots of stories and it's it's
actually like heartbreaking because a
lot of the time these men really care
for these women unless they're trapped
in this abusive you know what a lot of
girls trap guys by getting pregnant they
do it happens a lot and then they have
all this baby mum and dad's almost like
it's mad no but you know what it is yeah
when it comes to like trapping a man
with a baby you need to be careful who
you sleep with if you're sleeping with
people Loosely and you you run the risk
of getting that person pregnant so you
have to you have to sit like you don't
get back remember we said earlier about
if you you're only going into placement
date that person you don't that person
you want to be with them and you're
getting very short because of trust and
then you'd only speak with that person
if you're like jumping in that yeah at
the same time at the same time if you
don't want to make anything you need to
wrap up because yeah yeah as much as it
takes two to tango you need to protect
yourself for your own good like yeah
yeah the woman can say she's on the pill
she's on this she's on that but like but
still at the same time protect yourself
yes you said you've you've heard of a
girl trapping a guy tell me about that
um
we're just bait in people's businesses
obviously someone in the media industry
about who it is
but but what was I gonna say Obviously
um yeah he was obviously dating I think
this like girl only fans go and
um yeah and then obviously his energy
kind of Switched right and she was quite
um
talks I know she sucks because she used
to I have some other goals she's a block
she used to go on his phone and block
certain goals oh wow and um he used to
go and she'd go through people's like
insta stories
who who he follows that makes sense yeah
that makes sense yeah and then
afterwards
um
obviously who knows how she got pregnant
oh wow yeah and then um but obviously
again it was it was it wasn't serious he
was doing it mainly for pleasure because
of her body right she's got a nice body
okay cool what else can you bring to the
table you know we've got beautiful lady
panelists tonight we've all got body
body yeah but we you know what I mean
but we've got more than that hence why
we're here today that's right that's
what I'm trying to say but obviously in
the in that case I'm obviously trapping
him it's crazy because now it's messed
up his career a little bit he obviously
didn't want it he did not really taking
responsibility and he's kind of like
hiding away from everyone almost and
obviously that can impact the man
mentally as well and I think a lot of
people don't focus on a man's mental
health as well and I think females are
all we're all like are we emotional um
we've got feelings but obviously men are
taught to obviously keep that away but
but also what I would say is like once a
woman like when a woman actually falls
pregnant it's a very very very difficult
decision to make whether to keep it or
to get rid of it
how do you fall pregnant
yeah it's an actual baby so I mean you
might tell yourself oh I don't want a
baby and then you fall pregnant and
you're like oh [__] like what have I
done yeah what have I done like I
actually want to keep this baby now or
I'm gonna that's what I feel like a lot
of people do you guys don't think about
the consequences of your actions you're
always relying I feel like this
generation is so much awareness yeah
like are you present are you aware of
like what you're doing and the concept
Our Generation yeah mostly women yeah
women I would say women use it as a
formula I would say we use it as a form
of birth control which is not good which
is not good by the way I mean I know
people might have different
um views but I say that's not good
yeah I think if you don't want to get
pregnant then you need to like take the
precautions to not get pregnant
obviously if you need to have an
abortion and then like
the constellations because there's women
out there that can't have children and
then if you get a lot of abortions that
can actually stop you from having kids
in the future that is very true that is
very true because I took the pill so
many times I now suffer from polycystic
ovarian syndrome so it's hard for me to
actually get pregnant
unfortunately I haven't seen my period
for four years but recently I got my
period through some profit that prayed
for me and yeah I'm delivered guys
miracle from like from what did you get
it from the pill like like do you mean
the morning after pill or the the
morning after pill yeah I took that too
many times and I also went on the pill
how many times did you take it I think
like six seven times six seven times
within the span of how long
um within oh maybe like a month six
seven in a month wow yeah and did you
know that was a possible side effect no
I didn't and how did you find out that
you had that this was actually well what
the policy government yeah when I was in
a relationship with my toxic ex because
I noticed that he would obviously inside
of you and then I would notice that I
wasn't like getting pregnant and I was
gaining so much weight really quickly
and
um I started growing excess excess hair
in certain places so those are all the
side effects of getting um polycystic
ovarian syndromes and then I went to the
doctors found out I had it and yeah
what was that like for you it was scary
because I love kids I'm I am a child
myself you know like I love laughs I
love playing I love to just be me
everywhere so kids was a big factor for
me but I knew that in due time things
will work out in my favor and I will get
the kids that I want it's not impossible
not to have kids but it's harder 10
times harder do you wish they told you
about that um before you before I took
yes a thousand percent yeah it's um a
thousand percent because I feel like a
lot of girls really don't know about the
side effects and they don't discuss them
the doctors don't tell you I've never
really been on it because when I heard
about birth control I was like you're
gonna stop me from getting pregnant yeah
education in that aspect when it comes
to contraception methods it's not that
good the teacher a little bit at school
but not completely like but even when
you go and like get it prescribed the
doctor don't really tell you nothing and
you know what there's so many women that
go on contraception and then they can't
they struggle to get pregnant afterwards
utility goes back to normal straight
away and it doesn't and some people are
trying for a baby and three years down
the line they still can't have a child
because everyone is different as well
everyone's Body Works differently yeah
yeah it's hard
do you guys believe that the label toxic
is overused in relationships today yes
yeah
I mean look at me look at me like 10
whatever you've been liking about that
common now like really I don't know
hearing their stories that you know
there's different like I said it's
different um Heights of toxic levels of
toxicness and again it's what you
perceive the word toxic to mean so but I
do think that toxic relationships and
like just with anyone like friends
partners and stuff it's like really like
promoted on social media it is it is
it's like the toxic relationship
Lifestyles like toxic love like everyone
yeah and what's his name blue face
so much I don't get so much attention
for that and it's like so unhealthy
they're probably so both so depressed
and unhappy I feel like trying to be
toxic you have to have a very strong
head yeah like don't be toxic they know
what they're doing it's like they don't
it's not like they don't know what
they're doing it's like it's like it's
calculated yeah they're doing it on
purpose but what I've seen that's what
it looks like yeah I mean to be honest I
feel like with toxic relationships you
get that Adrenaline Rush from like when
things are good and then when it goes
like really bad you just think about the
good times which is why you stay with
that person you feel like you're making
excuses for yourself to stay yeah and
obviously it's so up and down like once
it goes down you're like oh my God I
can't wait for it to like go back up
again like and everything to be good
because you guys go through like really
good faces a little bit of Hope almost
yeah good part or sometimes you're just
used this is your comfort zone now yeah
the cons will eventually outweigh the
pose I mean that's when you know how do
you get used to it
no because some people have grown up in
even like a toxic household like with
toxic families like also like how
someone's been raised has a big impact
on like the type of men they go for
women also like drama
[Music]
why don't women watch sports that's
camaraderie we like the Kardashians oh
my God I love the Kardashians
[Laughter]
watch me in a year in a year's time I'm
gonna be sitting with Kim Kardashian
she's gonna be me and her gonna be
pretending that manifestation
we're working on you know skins X I've
got a private land dropping suit as well
joining my music so mad Madness told you
I'm such an EastEnders fan so I can't
you know what I like it
every single day but then the the
storyline is just too dark for me like
it's so negative at to a point you might
be able to handle it but like it got to
a point where I could not I could not
anymore but that is toxic actually
question what is toxic medicine where
does it come from
I think something that's not good for
you but you want it you go for it anyway
but something that's genuinely like bad
for your your mental health and I think
and you do it anyway a long duration
where does it stem from though
where does it stand from I think well
toxic relationships stem from lack of
boundaries I'm talking about toxic not
toxic relationship there's two different
toxic itself what is it thermostat
for food
[Music]
have you guys ever been labeled a toxic
X like would your exes say that you're
toxic yes yes yeah
no I haven't no
no
but I would say I could be toxic if I
choose to be toxic yeah
exactly that that's the energy yeah yeah
I agree with that that's what I said for
you to be toxic you have to have a
strong head that people know what they
do when they be toxic it's not like no
it's like a mind game 100 I agree what
do you think have you ever been labeled
to toxic ax would drugs to say you're
toxic they would they would say I'm
toxic maybe because I'm not admit as me
I'm toxic because um because
um
because I was in the past that was 10
minutes ago
but yeah I don't think I would be called
toxic
how how do you how do you guys think
past relationships shape future
relationships
you know the difference between lust and
love
oh my goodness you know the difference I
feel like if you're able to reflect if
you're able to reflect and not carry on
the patterns that you had in your past
relationship 100 you need to be
self-aware yeah 100 like Erica Perdue
said yes in that song bag lady she's
like Pack Light because if you bring all
your emotional baggage yeah into your
future relationships they're never gonna
work no one wants to deal with your bag
is she married now or no Erica I think
she's got a kid I don't know she's got
kids
really yeah wow I didn't I didn't know
who she was though
yeah she was cool though I love her
she's she's sick do you guys think that
the best predictor of uh future
relationships is past relationships yeah
yeah yeah I don't think so because I
feel like in life like if you go into a
relationship and you learn the lesson
that it's taught you after you've broken
up
then no but if you don't learn the
lesson then the universe is just going
to keep sending you the same person in a
different body and you're going to have
to keep
[Laughter]
us
wait wait wait wait wait I'm adding that
to my list of things like I want girls
to stop saying the universe but you know
what some people really genuinely
believe leave them no yeah the universe
does because if not if not why is it
that the same person with the same
character traits with the same habits
with the same comments again because you
can't take out a lesson
I can I can I can break it down for you
choices yeah no I'm saying like you
either like toxic you probably like
toxic people and you're probably toxic
at the same time
wait wait so girls girls will take
accountability off of them and say it's
the it's and I'm not trying to pick on
you but it's like they'll say the
universe and then it's like it might not
be the universe it's probably you but at
the same time though a lot of toxic
relationships don't start off toxic they
start off like normal relationships yeah
yeah and then they change they change
after the honeymoon phase that's true
what I would say is yeah poor choices
but it's because you haven't learned
your lesson the first time yeah exactly
and there's only so many relationships
you're going to go through before you
need to look inwards and be like okay
maybe I'm the problem yeah and I but
self-reflection is hard you know yeah
it might not start toxic but then you
probably do something that's toxic if
100 yeah no one's perfect so actually
relating to what you said it makes sense
because when you use an environment and
um
how it relates I feel like it makes
sense and when you said issue
environment and you so it all depends on
where you come from your upgrade
upbringing and what makes you who you
are so I feel like when you're in
relationship a past relationship can
make your future relationship better but
how that makes it better is by you
knowing yourself
[Music]
reflection if you don't reflecting
yourself or if you don't know yourself
or if you don't you battle if you
couldn't do the same thing it's like
wherever you see or whatever that is
what you're going to attract do any of
you guys go to the gym are you guys yeah
I guess sometimes I go so if you if
you're practicing squats you get better
at squatting right so wouldn't you say
the only way to get better at being in a
healthy relationship is to be in a
healthy relationship how would you I
would think so but also I think to be in
a healthy relationship you need to know
what your boundaries are and you need to
like respect them like going back to
boundaries again like if you have set
boundaries and you respect your own
boundaries and you have a level of
self-respect for yourself then it sets
the tone for other people to come into
your life and respect those boundaries
what kind of boundaries are helpful in a
relationship I think a level of trust
being able to give people space if they
need it okay trust you know not being
like controlling or anything and being
controlling okay yeah I mean everyone's
boundaries are kind of different it kind
of depends on the person but and I think
it also depends on that you've got to be
independent as a woman and be okay with
being on your own like you need to learn
to love yourself it's co-dependency that
really it believes it's like okay it's
cool he can leave you know what I mean
I've got a lot of girls rely a lot of
guys a lot of girls depends do you know
anyone that's been married for 30 plus
years
yeah 20 plus years not 20 20 plus years
do you feel like that's the woman's
mentality is I need a lot of boundaries
and I need to not need him
I don't think it's about not needing the
person but I think that's what there's a
fine line between like there could be
something having your own life and then
like codependence I mean like some some
like girls they make their relationship
their whole life and then they break up
with their partner and they're lost they
don't have no friends anymore because
they drop out all their friends right
because they don't know themselves they
lose their whole personality because
they've made their whole life their
relationship
I'm a couple years older than you and
usually those girls actually end up
getting into a relationship and starting
a family young so it's just like instead
of like you guys might have different
skills like you're good at singing
you're good at that those girls just
have relationship skills so usually they
just usually get into another religion I
mean they're heartbroken for a bit but
then they they find another guy because
she proves she could be a good
girlfriend to that one so that she goes
into another yeah some people are just
relationship people I think they're just
made to like be in a relationship some
people have the goals of like oh they're
just like young or they're just naive
and they just get taken advantage of
yeah there's a very very like
there's a very very fine line between
that I think because yeah there's a lot
of there is a fine line just make a man
their whole life because it gives them
validation because they don't love
themselves yeah and when you don't love
yourself like I know it's cliche but
like how can you expect someone to love
you properly if you don't love and
respect yourself how would you expect
them to love you yeah you need to set
the tone for them you know if you show
them that you don't respect yourself and
you don't love yourself then how are
they going to do how are they going to
love you and respect you so how do you
show them that I just I always hear
these terms with girls and I just it's
always so broad don't give them too many
chances you know what I mean you know
like yeah yeah don't give them too many
chances do you think the 30-year
marriage 20-year marriage
the longest marriage you know do you
think the woman's mentality was don't
give him too many chances no no I'm
talking about successful outcomes so if
we look at people with with good
outcomes because we don't agree long
marriage is better than nobody breaking
up right yeah yeah okay but I'm talking
I'm talking about like the dating like
when you're dating before you get into
it because like I said I haven't
actually been in a proper relationship
so I can only go for experience from
dating so I'm gonna say I know these
guys I think some of you have been a
relationships or no no
but like I I haven't so yeah but I feel
like you have to make sure what was the
question again do you think that do you
think that the mentality of cut a guy
off quick it was good for a long-term
relationship don't give him too many no
if he's cheating then yeah you've got it
because he will most likely do it why do
we always go to like the worst case
scenario I think I think
um because of female in the beginning I
think if someone like if you express
that you don't like how someone's
treating you and then they continue to
treat you like that and then you still
take them back that's unhealthy that's
not you not respecting your boundaries
because you don't like the way you're
being treated but you're gonna stay
there because you like him or you think
that he likes you because he does nasty
things to you and then he might buy you
some flowers afterwards and be like oh
I'm so sorry but then he does it again
marriage or you're in a relationship and
you have a few issues like you don't you
don't like agree on certain things those
things can easily be resolved with good
communication
yeah I mean I agree with you that you
should cut people off that aren't
married if you want to be married that
aren't marriage minded quick but I think
sometimes like as women we always jump
to like the worst case scenario it's
either cheating I only know this I've
done these shows so many times yeah we
have fantasies
to get better before I used to always
think of the worst case scenario but now
I'm like
um
I think sometimes you just gotta go with
the flow like yeah literally you do you
can't think too much into it obviously
if you're not being treated right then
obviously he's got to go yeah
100 it's as simple as that okay
um
can a person change and no longer be
considered a toxic X yes 100 I think
they can change when they look inwards
okay
um no
you don't think people can change no
depending on how long you're trying to
get them to change
depending on how long do you have no but
you know what it is a man or a woman
anyone will only change when they're
ready to change yeah force them to
change because they're never they're
never going to change for you like if
you stay with a man hoping that he will
change he's not gonna change for you
that influence when he's ready he's got
to be genuine as well it's got to be a
genuine change yeah like it's got a last
yeah and don't forget like sometimes you
know guys I'm sure go through stuff as
well like certain triggers might trigger
them to like step back toxic I'm not
toxic attributes to like you know come
back that aren't healthy
so that needs to be taken into our cat
as well when he makes that change that
has he completely like looked within
himself that we keep saying and like
what about you so for whatever well it's
just interesting whenever I say toxic
sex we always say man what about her huh
I think it's because we're all kind of
like yeah
yeah but like a toxic girl you know